hey guys welcome to episode
oops i said to the wrong camera we got
three cameras now hey guys
welcome to episode 200 a very special
episode
of congratulations
[Music]
hey what's up so we okay it's episode
200 i had no idea we were going to do
200 episodes
when we started this and uh we did and
i've had
my brother matt on before and i always
talk about my family and episode 200
is now and this is my father bill dalia
so i know everybody knows him
if you're if you're an avid listener of
the show then you know
about him but he's finally here and with
a little convincing
um actually you were all up for it but
whatever but anyway you can say any
words at any time
okay but when you first got here though
yeah go ahead
i want to hit this nice
[Music]
that's his intro did you get you got you
came in with a jeremy
i meant to hit that one i know but
previously on congratulations
i have to say that what do you mean
meant to hit it it literally says the
thing
okay hold on previously on
congratulations
what's this my dad directed what
now you can't just keep [ __ ] doing it
so okay we do that bit once
an episode now listen when we got here
you sat down
and you immediately started with
something negative and that's that's
shitty to do when you're a guest you did
do that you sat down and you said
hey guys what did you say what did i say
put this you got to talk into this what
did i say
i said hey guys you said hey guys you
don't remember what you said
no you said hey guys do you do this
every week right
and what did i say you remember now
right and i said yeah what do you mean
you listen to it and you you watch the
show and you listen to it
and then you said well then why does it
fit why does it seem like you guys
why does it take you this long to get it
together or whatever right yeah
yeah okay and then we said or i said
because
we had now have more cameras just in
case we want to pop in and get good
reactions out of both of us
and then also it's a whole different
setup when we added a microphone
okay and that was my answer okay but i
got
it no i understand but but uh you're in
the business
you're not in the podcasting business
but you know
that sometimes it takes extra time to do
[ __ ] right
okay okay so then don't you think that
you were disrespectful
i guess that's what my whole round thing
was okay
you don't think you're right that's
disrespectful okay cool yeah
it is i think you took a long time to
set this up right that's all
well yeah we kind of did you know
because we wanted it to be good for you
comfortable for you and now i understand
that we've never even had two chairs
back here honestly
got it i wore this uh billy shirt
for you because your name is william and
nobody really calls you billy but they
did when you were a kid at willy they
called you willy yeah
and i wore this sweatshirt life rips
for you that's very sweet and it's very
cool thank you and you can get that
actually at crystalia.com and
you can even wear it if you're if you're
73 too two
what are you up there you remember 73 i
think wow
you know what's funny is remember when i
used to say uh
no matter what age you were like
starting when you turned 50 i would
always say like happy 76 i can't believe
you're finally 73 i think it was 73
you're literally the age i would make
fun of you used to say that every year
yeah
when i hit 40 i think now i got to do
like 90.
yeah wow but that's great that's okay
you did it you're supposed to get old
and you did it
all right but you don't feel getting
older is to just keep doing it
keep doing it keep living yeah that's
like a very matthew mcconaughey thank
you you're getting older
just keep living man um
if you want to adjust that you can just
adjust it
[Music]
what i just hit you even you don't know
which one you hit huh
it was david caruso did you mean to hit
the david caruso one yeah okay
you just did that now i can hear it but
that talk in the [ __ ] mic but i
couldn't hear it okay
but that's fine but you can move the mic
okay do you want to move it like this
here where do you want me to move it
well just you have to talk into it
okay i thought i was talking to you you
now i hear you much better you know if
you had these on you'd be able to tell
okay
but you don't have to have those on when
i asked you to have these on no but when
i asked you
but also here like this god
like tighten it dude you're you're
you're a person
you know what to do that's the okay
there we go i got it
you see the difference i got it but also
okay just before we even get into the
show
uh you
said something that is very very very
very typically you before the show even
started when you were sitting down
and it wasn't a negative thing and this
is exactly
these are the stories i tell about you
on the podcast which you know because
you listen
but this is what you did was so
quintessentially you and i'm gonna tell
what it was it just happened
so you put on the headphones we said do
you want the headphones or not you said
i won't wear them and i said
well why don't you try them this way you
could have them on
and then if you like them you wear them
if not then no and you put them on
and and they took them off and said i'm
not going to wear them and i said yeah
is it because your glasses
they're uncomfortable and you said
yes it's too tight and those are two
different
things and also
nobody cares no but but i care and i'm
your son and i'm like one of the most
important people in your lives yeah
because if you don't say what you mean
then you have nothing basically by the
way
you're not one of the most important
people in my life okay
you're one of the most important people
in my life
right lives i said lives okay all right
so that's
tit for tat we both [ __ ] up yeah but
honestly
why this is a segment i wanted to do
with you and it's called why do you do
that
so why do you do that why do i do what
why do you do that where you say [ __ ]
like
like you agree with the negative and
then say something completely different
you're you're first of all you're making
me out to be
a negative person you're not negative
and you're not a negative no not at all
you are one of
you're actually one of the most you're
very very positive yeah yes you are i'm
an optimist you're not you're for sure
an optimist
i don't know if i am i don't think i am
i don't know if i am or not i i don't
know i always feel like things are going
to work out and then sometimes
when i get real depressed i think about
how everything has gone to [ __ ] i'm very
quick to that
but you're you've always been really
positive but why
do you do the thing about the words
thing i
cause i think it's funny you know so you
know what you're doing
i think it's funny to not answer the
question ah
and i like continuing things and
answering
in a way that doesn't make sense to you
okay i understand that but i think that
you
are i have two things to say about that
i think that you do it
and you don't know you're doing it
sometimes and here's the other thing
you get mad at me sometimes for doing it
but you created it or your family did i
mean uncle vinnie and uncle richard are
the same way
but bam wasn't like that was it your dad
grandpa bam
was he like that i don't remember but
what about
other people because i didn't pay
attention to it like you do
mainly because you do [ __ ] like that
where you say
oh it's because of your glasses and then
you'll say yeah it's too tight
and it just drives me [ __ ] nuts
doesn't that mean
yes it's because of my glasses and it's
too tight
aren't i still answering the question
yeah
but you don't say it the the way to
where oh but you're also
adding information
that's basically what you're saying i'm
not answering the question
the way you want me to answer the
question okay well
i think that generally you know what i'm
talking about and also we need to
uh come to a better understanding about
that and but i'm still very young i'm 41
and you're 73 or something like that and
we can
absolutely uh we should work on that so
that's good that we're figuring out
things to work on on this podcast that
we may not
under normal circumstances so in a way
this is a bit like family therapy i
really appreciate that
but also what were you gonna say
something no
yes but you were though so you just did
the same thing you went like this
and you were about to say something
because i know you weren't about to sing
so what
what were you going to say you don't
remember now you don't remember and now
that's what pisses me off the [ __ ]
mouse
but uh first of all why don't you
just ask me another question okay and
then
and then i'll answer but but i have a
whole slew of things
that i can even refer to okay that
you like people on the podcast
are always like we want to get bill's
take on this
because i talked about it but like what
um what was the i actually wrote it down
hold on because i
[ __ ] never remember [ __ ] um by the
way
what you mostly tell family stories
wrong no that's such [ __ ] no you
tell them wrong how do i tell them wrong
because you get the facts twisted no way
yeah you do hold on
for example okay you told the story
about my grandfather
yes stealing from the druggist
yes oh yeah and you made it seem
like it was my father okay it wasn't my
father was just a different person
okay it was your grandfather i i knew
that
did i say your father yeah and um
my grandfather stole from the druggist
and the druggist called my dad and
and asked my dad to
ask him to stop right and the
my grandfather said to my father when he
told him that um
he's stealing from me i'm gonna steal
from him
he knows that he's stealing from me
right and i know
right so he
it was like tit for tat yeah don't you
think honestly
that in a way that created me yeah
like in a way him him and that attitude
that's like i live by that i think that
that's awesome that he did that yeah do
you think that that's awesome that he
did
you think that's wrong i think it's
funny yeah it is funny
wow you're very political i think it's
hysterical it is funny
and it's fun to know that you came from
that
yeah it is funny huh the the the one
the the one thing what was the [ __ ]
one that kristen
kristen just brought up that i wanted to
talk about or you brought it up
it was just the thing that was funny and
i was like i don't want it but it's not
here is it
hold on let's just we can cut this out
if we want
the toaster [ __ ] thing that's the
main thing
that everybody that that's the thing
about the toaster i had the breville
thing right here and it was like
we don't need it but this is your this
is the thing that i ended up getting
because you said
to get it or you were raving about i
want basically what i want to do is i
want you to talk about the toaster that
you have first of all
and i want you to talk about why it's
good and why you like it
it's a toaster no but now you're making
it seem like when everybody already
knows the deal you're making it seem
like you don't really care about it
but that i spent a lot of money for a
taste it's not even that it's
what is what are the buttons on the
toaster that are so [ __ ] annoying and
you should know that
you're annoyed by the buttons on the
toast it's
it's it the buttons on the toaster
what's up
oh talk in the mic okay
the buttons on the toaster say
toast yeah bagel
yeah a bit more
take a look take a look yeah you can hit
a button
and um oh and it comes up a little bit
to see it and it goes back down
yeah okay and that that's and you like
the toaster
yeah is it the best toast you've had
yeah
all of those buttons are the same
buttons i have news for you they're all
the same button
but they don't do the same thing but
they do though
kind of in a way what are you talking
about because there's one thing a
toaster does
it toasts yeah and then it stops
toasting right
there's two things right it toasts and
stops toasting right
every button you hit either toasts it or
stops toasting it
even if it's just for a little bit so
you don't even so first of all you don't
need a little bit more you don't need
the button that's a little bit more
here's the thing what i think that you
did you saw it
and you like it you were a cuda about it
you were sparkly it was sparkly because
of the
a little bit more button and the take a
peek button those are the same things as
the other buttons the on button
okay first of all you're wrong okay
and second of all it was not a cuda
thing
it was not a sparkly thing it was just
i wanted to get a toaster and stop
buying toasters
i wanted to get the toaster that would
end me from buying
any toaster ever again and why is that
that toaster
because it has all those buttons so you
so basically what you're saying in
essence is you always wanted
a toaster that had a little bit more
button no i didn't always want the
toaster
okay why not then what do you mean
button on it
but the fact that it had those buttons
made it it's better but that's what
that's what like somebody who's like
a coded what that could have done okay
you know what a cuda is
okay right yeah yeah okay because you've
listened to the episodes
yeah so now you're just willing to
accept that
or is it acceptance or is it i don't
care yeah i i i i don't give a [ __ ]
okay i think it's i don't give a [ __ ]
okay
yeah i mean if you don't give a [ __ ]
only you know that yeah
so so you're telling me you don't give a
[ __ ] yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
don't it's so annoying dude
is that happening again no it's not it's
a different thing but it's
it's it's fine it's fine i i love that
you do it but also
you got to understand that you do it and
you also have to understand
i don't even know what you're talking
about
okay well fine fine explain it no i'm
just saying
we're spending too much time on this but
you okay no it's fine it's good but you
you you know what it is like
no yeah i know no but i'm gonna explain
it okay
you don't know what it's like you throw
this [ __ ] out there
and it and it and it works and it riles
me up
and then you act like you don't care
about it
but it's like it's like it's like
teasing
in the most grandmaster way maybe that's
why i do it
yeah but that's [ __ ] sucks it's
[ __ ] but i love it
but don't change it it's just part of
the fabric
of me yeah part of the fabric that's who
i am that is the most [ __ ] way to say
anything but
as part of the fabric of me okay
that's part of the fabric of me is [ __ ]
so what else do you have on that list i
i have stuff on the list if i need to go
to it just to remember but
we don't need to go to it i mean i have
stuff but we talked about the post the
toaster and then there's other stuff
that you did
that was [ __ ] that we could talk
about but i don't even care about that
necessarily um and also i i'm not in
like an interviewer and we're not doing
that obviously you've seen matt's on the
thing we just kind of talk and make fun
of stuff
but what do you um
how much you love me
like how much do you love me because i
had a kid because i had a kid
like 16 months ago right
and um it's unbelievable
it's crazy it's the craziest thing ever
it's
it's you can't describe it right no you
can't describe it you cannot
yeah which is you can describe
everything else
yeah i think i think that's the thing
about it almost everything else
really can you describe your love of
someone anyone well so here's the thing
you can say
have you ever loved someone and they say
yes and then you say
it's like that but if you haven't had a
kid
you can't say it's like that's a whole
other level because they have nothing to
draw it from
right because it's not like having a pet
right that you love a pet
but it's not like having a dad it's not
like having a a a
a brother sister or a wife or whatever
and
and also it's it's not like you could
say
if an alien came down i've said this
before but if an alien came down and
they were like what's baseball like
you'd be like have you seen football and
they'd be like as a matter of fact i
have and you'd be like okay well it's
kind of like that only different
but you can't do that with a kid it's
literally like nothing else
so i wouldn't tell an alien
that baseball is like football okay i
wouldn't do that
i mean so missing the point in to even
hang on that
and hang that on no it's just a bad
example okay it's
it's a fine example what would you say
it's a bad example what would you say
hello i'm so i'm an alien hey i came
down to earth
what is baseball like what's baseball i
heard about baseball what's baseball
like
let's go to a game dude
that's not describing what baseball's
like
let's go to a game what why not show you
what it's like what game no but i don't
have time my spacecraft
leaves and i don't have your number you
need to tell me what it's like quick
there's a quiz when i get back to mars
i'll see you next time
no no i please i came to one person see
this
is yours i ask how do you describe
baseball and you say let's go to a game
yeah right assume i don't even know what
a game is
right so you you don't just say
i'll see you next time to an alien
why not we're making this [ __ ] up anyway
yeah okay
so so you're not an alien you're making
believe you're an
alien yeah and i'm making believe i'm me
meeting an alien which is
absurd to start with okay
you hung on to the thing i'm just trying
to tell you that
having a kid is crazy and you know that
and how much do you love me
when you were born yeah it was
like when you experienced calvin being
born yeah
it was unlike anything i'd ever felt
and i felt like i could conquer
anything because you were in the world
isn't that weird it's
because i remember i would text you like
a few first few months he was born and
i'd be like
i can't believe how much like love you
have
for a kid like and you said that's how i
now i know now you know that's how i
felt when when
when you mostly you but also a little
bit matt you said
you and matt is what i said chris you
mostly but also matt a little bit
that's exactly what i didn't say i know
i know you didn't and i know we have to
go on record to say you didn't say that
you said that you know because you love
us both equally
but oh but also remember dude
i don't know if i ever said this on the
podcast but matt and i always [ __ ]
talk about it
about how you said when we were in italy
and then i was dressed with the green
shirt and the rose tinted sunglasses
and matt was dressed i guess a little
bit more normal and you were like hey
matt you look great and then you saw me
and you said hey chris you look funky
yeah that's so d that's so [ __ ] up
it's seared into my brain
that happened i know and i'm different
because of it how do you feel about that
i know i've never stopped thinking about
it you never know when you're gonna [ __ ]
your kids up is my point
yeah you never know but you are gonna
[ __ ] your kid
up i know that's like kind of that's
scary you know
why well because what if it's real bad
you know like i have like you're not
going to do anything yeah
true you're just going to do stupid [ __ ]
yeah you're funky you look funky yeah
yeah i love when those kinds of moments
happen though and then you don't know
they're going to happen and then they
happen
and you're like oh immediately that's
why by the way
when that happened sure yeah i saw matt
first i know
and then you walked in the room second
that's how i described it though
yeah yeah so what the [ __ ] that have
to do with anything
why did you go back and say that part i
don't know
you don't even know i don't know you
don't even know why you said that i
don't know
that's unbelievable you know why you did
everything why you do everything no i
don't know why i do everything but i try
real hard
i don't ah you one of my friends also
said once
about you that you never fidget and you
really don't
you're real chill yeah
how do you do that
you just relax pretty much wherever you
are you just don't fidget
yeah okay why can't i just be chill
um who said i don't fidget um it was
ryan davis that said that that you were
fidgety
that i wasn't that you're not fidgety
ryan davis said it he's like come here
that doesn't fidget and
i was like oh yeah he doesn't huh does
everybody fidget
i mean yeah everybody else fidgets yeah
you're like james bond
it's a it's like you're a movie
character only you don't really do high
octane [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying you're just
like chill it's like james bond after he
retired that's what you're like
you're just like don't fidget and you're
just like i've seen it all but you
haven't even seen
like but when ryan davis said that yeah
i was 20 years younger right than i am
but you're not fidget
you're very um like for someone in their
70s you're very
like you can just like you can squat
down on your knees and get back
up yeah you have like no hunch and [ __ ]
right all your hair right
what do you think that's from eating
scents that was all my hair yeah yeah
eating all eating like salads and tuna
and [ __ ] no
it's just you're on your feet a lot
but also it's just the luck of the draw
i think that's so disheartening
you know what i mean like some guys are
like
[ __ ] 50 and look older than you some
guys are old
when they're 40. yeah true some guys are
forever young yeah i always feel young
i feel like i'm your age still except
when i look at you
uh-huh or if you catch yourself in the
mirror
when i see myself in the mirror i can
convince myself
that i still look the same wow when i
see a picture picture yeah yeah yeah
that's when i realized who the [ __ ] is
that old guy that's funny because i do
that too when i see a picture of me i
notice i'm older but
not when it's only with pictures yeah
it's interesting
you know do you think it has anything to
do with like everyone has their mirror
face and they do what they do but they
don't do it for the picture because they
can't tell what they're doing in the
picture
because i have a mirror face i think you
can fool yourself looking into a mirror
yeah
and you can't fool yourself when you're
looking at a picture yeah we used to
make fun of you with your mirror face do
you remember that
yeah i definitely have a mirror face
yeah but i think most people do i do
um mine's like this
um but that's a good one yeah um wait
hold on
what was i gonna say about the [ __ ]
thing
i don't remember i don't remember what i
was to say about the thing
see that's good the good thing about
this podcast is that when i forget i
just keep talking and go go to say
whatever i'm going to say
but that's it's a little trickier with
someone else oh that's the good thing
about this podcast yeah
there's not much trust me that's the
good thing
but uh oh if you want sign up for our
patreon it's patreon.com
crystalia and to
and all that i did yeah you're a patreon
subscriber right yeah
that's really cool because you
definitely don't have to which is which
is
nice you always wanted to support huh
you always wanted to support
like you've seen every episode of this
yeah you've seen every episode of
anything really i've done yeah and
you came to all the baseball games that
i used to do
uh baseball's not like football and um
and i tell that to an alien yeah and i
not
and i and i have not really seen i have
not seen everything you've done but that
would be too hard though because i was
born
already when you were 30 or something
yeah but you could catch up yeah
well now that everything's streaming
yeah um i'm disappointed that you
haven't
yeah well that makes one of us honestly
but that's good
i i do have to catch up on your show big
shot right that's what it's called
yeah yeah with uh with johnston on
disney plus i love him yeah
oh yeah you could [ __ ] do like a plug
here i didn't even realize that
um all episodes streaming now yep
are you going to do a second season you
don't know yet i don't know yet yeah
okay well i hope so yeah
um what's up with
okay one thing we have in common we both
love coffee
yeah you say you love coffee no i only
drink
hot coffee right that's where we differ
right
can i drink iced coffee did you catch
that listeners the way he did it
did you catch it okay i just want you to
catch this [ __ ] so you know what i'm
talking about it again
all right so you didn't even realize you
did it so you say you always know when
you're doing it but you don't know when
you're but i did it again no because so
what you did was i said we both love
coffee huh do you love coffee and
and i said we both love coffee huh and
you said
no i drink hot coffee that's
insane to say that that way no that's
not insane i'm not saying not exactly
what
i just want the viewers technically in
real time that's not exactly what
happened so what's exactly what happened
what happened is you asked me
do i love coffee and i said no
but you like cold coffee and i like
hot cocoa okay all right you know what
this is honestly a perfect time to do
this
do what
previously on this episode
[Music]
you say you love coffee no i only drink
hot coffee right that's where we differ
right
okay i drink iced coffee did you catch
that listeners the way he did it
did you catch it okay so now that we cut
that in
that's what happened okay that's what
happened now we don't know because we're
sitting here right now
but the viewers will be able to tell and
when we see it we'll see what happened
but i'm pretty sure i was right but you
might be right but i think it was me
because they started laughing even
before i pointed it out behind us
here's why you're wrong okay because you
tell the stories
about the family yeah incorrectly
no and we should move on because you
always tell them from your perspective
as if
you are the center of the story all the
time
thank you and you're not the you're
saying center of the story all the time
i am though because i'm me
and i'm no one else but when you tell a
story
yeah you have to tell the story from the
perspective
of the story happening not
from the perspective of
i am the center of it that might be
the worst advice for a stand-up comedian
though
because you have to be like this is what
happened and this is how i feel about it
this isn't npr okay and you know what i
say about npr
[ __ ] npr yeah but you list you probably
listen to npr but um
so you only drink hot coffee yeah you
don't drink iced coffee
no why never because why
coffee should be hot okay i like that
you're taking a stains you know that but
why
because coffee is hot unbelievable
is this a children's book why i like
iced coffee
i like hot coffee why would you be hot
bill says i don't like it
i i don't like the way it tastes when
it's cold
i only like the way it tastes when it's
hot do you think that iced coffee tastes
the same as hot coffee except for the
temperature
no i but i agree with you i agree with
you i like both
um so but you drink coffee
i only drink a couple of cups a day okay
so but would you say which is my
original [ __ ] question
that you love it no okay i don't love it
okay i like it okay so you and you drink
it because it wakes you up maybe
yeah okay fine this tea thing
remember when you started drinking tea
at night yeah okay sleepy time tea
all right just don't even let me don't
get ahead of everything all right
i said to you i noticed you were
drinking you only drink coffee till when
what like 11 p.m or 11 a.m in the
morning yeah
okay so i noticed he had a coffee cup
and he was drinking it at
like 9 30 p.m and i was like
what what is your camera you're drinking
coffee so late and you said
it's tea and i said oh wow
i didn't know you drink tea at night and
you said yeah i do it
every night before i go to bed and i
said really
and you said yes and i said that's crazy
i said does it work
and you said i don't know because i i've
i've i haven't been doing it that long
and i said
when did you start and you said
yesterday
okay so why did you say
i do it every night before i go to bed
when you don't even have a streak
you literally started it the day before
this was the second time you were
drinking it you're going to let me
answer
yeah but i got to get all the points out
okay okay go ahead
it was fun to do that so you
knew you brought right when i said that
you thought i'm gonna have fun doing
this
no okay so then no it just developed
that way
so you knew what you were doing from
jump no so then what the [ __ ] are you
saying
what i'm saying is that as the story
as the conversation progressed i decided
to [ __ ] with you why not all right
yeah fine but i just it's like that was
so funny i didn't plan it
right ahead of time i got it
it just developed that way okay
look that's fine your brother
uncle vinnie my uncle vinnie has two
wallets yeah okay
i've talked about on the podcast before
uh he is probably
honestly when it comes to this [ __ ] he's
probably
me on steroids would you say like with
the
with the why why did you say that when
you said it like this
or you think i'm worse i don't know what
you mean
what do you mean you on steroids the
thing about okay i don't mean he's a
muscular me
like i don't mean like steroids but i
mean like what do you mean
about the two wallets okay so he has two
wallets
and you don't i don't i have one wallet
yeah just like you
yeah but he has two wallets why because
he likes to keep
different things in different wallets
right so if he gets
if he gets uh robbed
he can give a guy the money the wallet
with the less [ __ ] in it
he can give the guy the wallet with just
the ones in it
that's what he does and he really does
carry around two wallets right yeah
okay so i want this is something i bring
up because i want
the fans of this podcast to understand
that i i don't lie about this [ __ ]
you you are backing me up about this
yeah great so
that's a true story my whole family's
crazy yeah yeah because of that okay
good i just want you to know that
he's nuts yeah he is not my brother is
nuts
more nuts than uncle richard yeah what
is the deal with that growing up with
him
that he was always nuts or what no no
i think he became nuts as he became an
adult
right that's what i'm doing yeah
that's for sure what i'm doing that's
you on steroids that's
what you know i'm saying yeah i don't
know if i'm that way
that much like i don't have two wallets
but i'm definitely specific about other
things
yeah but i think he might be are
specific about
too many things like what
like every conversation we have right
like every conversation we have is true
like when you say the thing about the
headsets
right and the glasses
if yeah all right okay fair enough or
making a deal
out of the calamari right okay
so you listened to this and you were
saying how i you
i didn't tell that wrong the calamari
thing no you told that
from your perspective which was
incorrect
okay so here's what happened
we i don't eat column i never eat i've
never eat i've never had calamari did
you know that
no okay you should listen to me more
because i've said that a lot i know that
now
um uh you were eating calamari
and you went to fork
some calamari right right or
i'm just going to tell it because i
don't know if you remember but you
got two i remember okay well why don't
you want me to tell it okay well i'll
tell you tell me what's wrong okay all
right
so you forked the calamari bowl you got
two one was secure on the fork the other
one
was dangling a little bit you went to go
dip the calamari into the sauce
the dangly one fell in the other one got
a little bit of sauce on it
so you were like okay forget it
ate the one calamari right with a little
bit of sauce on it then
grab the other calamari we had so much
sauce on it because you dropped it in
and then you ate that one right right
and i asked you which one
i asked you how much sauce do you like
on your calamari
do you put a generous amount like that
second one
or do you put just a little bit each
time
and you you said i don't care right
right what's wrong about that that's all
correct okay
so my point is we talked about for like
a half an hour at dinner
you don't eat all of your calamari at
the same the same with the same amount
of sauce
this this blow this blows my mind here's
your thing okay what here's the thing
that bugs me about
what you're saying okay you also talked
about
how much meat you put in a pasta dish
yes this blows my mind
but you you think
that everybody gives that thought
when there's no thought involved in
eating
you just eat that so but isn't
what you do who you are in a way yeah
so in a way you don't know who you are
is what you're admitting
no if if i'm gonna get a bowl of pasta
no
who i am is somebody that doesn't care
about what happened to the calamari
doesn't care how many pieces of meat are
in the pasta dish
okay so i like about four pieces of meat
in my pasta dish
yeah you said three four right five to
me would be too much
you don't think about it right right you
just put pasta
and meat in the bowl right cool great
cool so we figured it out
now if you had only gotten three meats
in the pasta bowl
and you noticed that then what i'd eat
them
okay if you got four then what i'd eat
them okay
if you got five then what i'd eat them
and if you got six then what
okay and if you got seven then what
[Music]
who knows okay but i want to i have the
same amount of pasta
each time or what am i imagining
what i want a little less pasta and more
meat the same
same amount same bowl the same bowl the
same amount of pasta yeah
you'd eat the six ones if you got seven
what would you do if you got seven in
that same amount of possible oh that's
too many
okay so we know so we know then you like
about
five you know six is a lot
meats and you're possible three or four
is plenty
oh my god so now you actually know so
you knew
you know the whole time because you made
me think that it is insane
to me you made me think about it and i
don't
think about it i think you do no
i don't do i think you you visually see
it
because you'd never put nine pieces of
meat in the pasta
this is what all podcasts should be
about you might put
nine pieces of meat in the pasta if you
have less pasta
what honestly what do you even mean
what do you mean i mean you want to fill
up on me that not pasta felt
yeah okay that's what i mean but you
don't do that
so why are you giving a hypothetical
because this is all hypothetical
it's really not though in a way that
part
it's fine the fact that you care about
this
is ridiculous but of course i care about
what my food is going to be
it's ridiculous okay okay fine
yeah hold on one second we got to do it
like this
i don't know why it keeps doing that
that's it you did it a piece of
[ __ ] pasta flying across the thing
nice all right
look wait okay when i watch your podcast
i always want to hit those buttons well
you you can now and honestly uh i'm sure
a lot of people do
that's why i came here i just want to
hit the buttons
okay i got other why do you do that
we talked about the calamari why do you
always cheat at games
because it's fun board games and any
kinds of games guessing games
i i want people to know
ahead of time that i'm gonna cheat okay
and that's part of the fun of the game
for me okay what's remember the thing
you told about how mom was calling you
and telling you the
what was the thing a long time ago that
was a specific thing i know but that's
hilarious
when we lived in new jersey yeah and
i was shooting a commercial out here in
california and there were no cell phones
at the time and it was a car commercial
and we finished the car commercial early
you were shooting a car commercial you
got it
are we back yeah if you want to be okay
all right we have to take a break
because it's got so hot and we had to
take over
off of his really great life rip uh
hoodie but
you were talking about and you
you'd like to cheat at games yeah
because you think it makes games more
fun
yeah which i agree with you because i
don't like games yeah
um basically i don't like games right
okay and so
i let people know ahead of time if
there's a way to cheat
i'm gonna cheat yeah and i let them try
to catch me
and if they catch me that's fun for you
and if i get away with it
that's more fun right so you
okay so all right so but okay and then
there was this one time
okay so when you the story i was telling
was about the car commercial
and how old were you this was before me
yeah okay you might have been a baby
at the time right i was doing a car
commercial
here in california i was directing a
and we finished the commercial in front
of a building
and there were no cell phones at the
time yeah
so i went into the building to make a
call
to call home i called your mother
and she said
um i can't talk right now i'm watching
jeopardy
and she said i need to get the final
jeopardy answered
yeah and and then i got mad at her we
had a fight
she said because she couldn't talk yeah
okay she wouldn't talk to me because of
a television show
yeah that's annoying so i got mad at her
okay she said
okay queen victoria is the answer i can
talk now
got it so you remember queen victoria
yeah wow
and then wow i didn't want to talk to
her and i hung up
because i said i don't want to talk now
interesting
oh i didn't know that that's how it's
starting to show is more important than
talking to me
then i don't want to talk to you
interesting i like that so
that night
in my apartment i was staying at the
oakwood apartments here in
california yeah wow i don't think
they're open
anymore but yeah they're not the
operator anymore but
uh we were here for a series of
commercials
it was a package okay so we were staying
there for
like a couple of weeks and um
danny oh really okay well i didn't know
it's him yeah your uncle danny yeah yeah
he was taking me out to dinner that
night and he we were going to dinner
that night
and he was coming to pick me up yeah and
the tv was on
and jeopardy was on
right and i thought to myself could this
be the same
show that mom was watching yeah
i bet it is it's syndicated yeah
it's three hours later
in california and they're running the
same show right
so i said to denny
you know it's uncanny but i
always get the final answer
i don't know why i don't know what it is
about me
but i can get a lot of the answers
incorrect
but when it comes to the final deputy
answer i always get it
that's the stupidest [ __ ] and and he
that's what he said oh yeah he said that
can't be
and i said i bet i get it tonight and
the question was about clearly the
answer
could have been queen victor oh yeah
yeah so
i said i don't know why but i think it's
queen victoria
he said that's amazing because you got
it right
yeah yeah and i said to him
i'll get it right all this week
[Laughter]
i'll bet you that i get it right every
night
okay and so every night on set we'd
wheel
a tv onto the set and we get to the
final jeopardy answer
and i called your mother that
and i said no matter what happens
i'm going to call you around 4 30.
yeah and i want you regardless of what
we're talking about yes
to give me the final jeopardy answer you
have to watch jeopardy every day okay
okay so and she said okay
yeah okay she did that and so i said
no matter what we're talking about you
have to give me the final jeopardy
answer
we were talking about the kids you guys
or whatever
the weather and she would say the 1939
world's fair
because i would say it out loud yeah i
would just continue
because you didn't want them to hear you
yeah
and uh and so okay every night
i would wheel the tv in yeah
and get the final jeopardy answer okay
and then denny said to me right after
three nights of this oh okay i remember
you said i know what's going on
right you're getting the answers
from ellie back in new jersey
and she's watching the show and she's
giving you the answers
right right and i said indignantly
how dare you accuse me of that yeah
that's
absurd for as long as you know me yeah
why would you think i would stoop to
something like that
wow i mean you really laid it on thick
yeah okay
and he's apologized
okay he apologized he was right and he
apologized
okay cut to the end of the week he
drives me to the airport
i get out of the car and i say to him
by the way i meant to tell you you were
right
i was getting the answers from ellie she
was watching the show every night
she was giving me the answers to final
jeopardy
and i said here's the mistake you made
you love me so you believe me yeah
you shouldn't have done that you should
have just trusted yourself
this is like the like the first draft of
a bronx tale this is the worst
lesson to teach somebody hey you were
wrong about jeopardy
but that's what i did i was calling my
wife and getting the answers but that's
what i did
that's so that's the story ridiculous
yeah and by the way there's something i
need to tell you but it was fun remember
when you brought up jeopardy
it was a lot of fun you made a grave
mistake you
you trusted me just because you loved me
in real life don't make that mistake you
wind up with two in your head
that's exactly what happened except for
the two in your headphones
that wow i thank god i have a dad that
did [ __ ] like that
because most dads just are like hi how
you doing and how's the weather
i think that that's great you know when
i actually thought about that made me
think of this for some reason
but when you when you um
took me to my first baseball game i
think that
this might be why i don't like sports
what
happened how first of all how old old
was i
it was the mets versus the pittsburgh
pirates
and you were for it's crazy the [ __ ] you
remember
you remember was versus the pirates you
probably still have the [ __ ] stubs or
something i have someone
yeah i have the tickets and the article
that was in the paper the next day
right because of what happened during
the game okay so no
because i brought you no no no no no i
know that but that's why i said what
happened
tell the story because you it was my
first game
i had never i actually remember this i
was four and i remember
feeling the anger uh and it's one of
those memories yeah okay go ahead
uh i had never seen a grand slam
[Music]
daryl strawberry gets up with the bases
loaded
and hits a grand slam first inning right
yeah wasn't it the first inning yeah
okay i think it was the first inning
yeah and
um it might have been second order
whatever but
i don't remember that everybody in the
stadium
jumped up and screamed
bloody murder yeah right because of
nicholas and darrell strawberry one of
the faves
and as i'm on my feet applauding
and screaming i think to myself i wonder
how the kid's taking this
and i look down at you and you're crying
your eyes out yeah
and i say what's wrong and
you said i can take it that it's cold
i can take it that i don't know what's
going on
but when everybody stands up and gets
mad at me like
that i don't like it
dude thinking i took you out and i
bought you
t-shirts and pennants and candy
and hot dogs and whatever i could buy
i didn't like to be it made me so scared
i remember thinking
how scared i was that you were all the
crying your eyes out
the sound of it i hated it
it was so deafening and loud and i
remember also grandpa [ __ ] laughed at
me
grandpa your dad turned around and
laughed at me he's like why are you
[ __ ] crying yeah it isn't a grand
slam i'm like i don't even know what
baseball is that would be him
yeah that would be my dad i [ __ ] love
i
loved your dad i remember even
as a kid
like when he would be like because he
had his chair
you know in queens in his house archie
bunker
yeah he just had to have the chair and
he would always sit in his chair
and if somebody was sitting in the chair
he'd make you get up that's what i was
going to say is i remember i
sat in it once one time
and he came back and he just goes
and and then i got i got out and i
remember as a kid thinking like that's
so [ __ ] cool he has his chair and
like nobody says [ __ ] about it
and like like to me like that's what it
was being
like a homeowner like you could just and
and like being
like because he was older than everybody
he had his chair i was like i can't wait
to have my chair
you know and i don't even have my chair
now this is my chair but like
um i remember thinking that about him
everybody should have their chair yeah
you
do you remember
when you were yelling at me once in
high school and i was you i think you'll
remember this
what was i yelling about i don't know
what it was about what'd you do you
weren't yelling but you were like having
a talk with me it definitely weren't
yelling but it was like a sit down like
you were sitting me down saying like you
can't do this and when this happens you
do that and that
and i said uh and you and i said
okay and and you said do you have
anything that you
want or have to say about that or any
questions and
and i said no and you said well what are
you thinking about and i said
your ears are just like grandpa's yeah
you remember that
except the conversation was this oh you
remember what it was about remember the
exact conversation okay okay what
it was when you were like
15. yeah i was in high school for sure
yeah and
that was the age where you stopped
wanting to be with your parents oh yeah
and and we sat down
i sat you down to talk to you about why
that's right and you said
dad it's just the age i'm going through
you
probably went through this with your dad
all right i remember yeah
and i said yeah but my dad was an
[ __ ] i'm cool right
which was the wrong thing to say right
right right then you said
nah you're not cool well i think
at 15 i wasn't cool right but i but then
what did i say i said the thing about
how
then you sit yeah yeah no i said about
how it was only going to last a few
years yeah you remember that because i
was like
it's not cool to hang out with your dad
when you're like a sophomore um
uh junior senior in high school right
and then once you're out of the house
or in college it's cool again right and
i said so just bear with me for a few
years
you were smarter than me at that moment
yeah
because you knew that was gonna happen
and it
and it did and it would and then we
would i would come back from college and
we could hang out again
i don't know what the [ __ ] it is about
that [ __ ] though it's so weird like i
remember
feeling embarrassed when i was
out with you and i would see either
girls or some of my friends
and i had in their in my mind they were
like oh chris is with his dad loser
just know that cal is gonna do that too
i know it's gonna happen i know i i
suppose i dread it but i do remember
that i remember the feeling and i
remember that conversation we had so i
am prepared for it and um
i'll tell him this or i'll just show him
this clip actually
that's uh that's so i
i just can't believe he's gonna be sick
what the [ __ ] is it like to see your kid
grow up and now i'm 41.
it's pretty amazing i mean like like
like i saw a five-year-old today i was
at a
i can't remember where i was somewhere
with kristen but i just saw a
five-year-old and like
cal's one and a half and i'm just like i
can't believe
he's gonna be like talking to me and
[ __ ] and the five-year-old had a hat on
and i'm like cow's gonna have a hat one
day
like that he wants to wear and [ __ ]
whitley tells you
no for the first time yeah and means it
yeah he doesn't do that now he just goes
yeah he'll look at you and say no
i remember that with you and your
brother
the first like the first few times i
said first time you said no
what the [ __ ] what do you mean no
i'm in charge here you do what i say
what do you mean no and then i made no
sense stuck to it
yeah and i didn't do it of course i'm
[ __ ] that's good that's good for me
i'm glad i did i am glad i did that
that's what kids do um
[Music]
what yeah that is what kids do but i
don't know i see other kids parent like
or other parents parent than the way
they parent and sometimes i'm like
you're not
you gotta [ __ ] they'll be like nah
don't all right okay then
and they're just running around and [ __ ]
and i'm like dude i'm not gonna do that
but do you give up a little bit like are
you like all right yeah
you gotta acquiesce a little bit [ __ ]
intel dogs hey
you can't give up yeah you can't right
you can't give up
because then you have to present all
over the united front
wow political your wife and
you can't give in yeah
is um
okay let's see there's other things i
want to talk about but
that is uh very sweet
and very nice by the way once i
won at trivial pursuit and nobody could
believe that i didn't cheat
and i didn't cheat and you did win yeah
i won
legitimately and then with your mom
and aunt michelle oh yeah you've told me
this and
they couldn't believe i knew the answer
what was the answer but i didn't cheat
if it was queen victoria that yeah if it
was full i don't remember the answer
yeah
um that's [ __ ] up that you remember
the cheat answer but not the real answer
when you did win
um
that's not [ __ ] up no maybe i don't
know
i i don't really have conviction with
that to be honest what's up with uh you
have conviction
about everything else i know things that
really like here's another thing too
things that don't matter i know i i i
convinced you it might be my ocd
it might be it might be my ocd i think
then well because like
like if i think about like if i really
think about it like the fact that you
have a carton of whole milk in your
fridge
and not just the little whole milk
bullshits or half an ounce
you don't have a you have a whole carton
of half and half yeah
because why
because i bought it okay so i was home
a lot and i was using the half and half
a lot yeah and so the little pint
containers
weren't enough right because as you know
and as you've established yeah i love
coffee right so hold on a second what do
you mean the little ones aren't enough
i would run out of the pint and have to
buy
more of them more frequently so if i
bought
the quart it would last longer okay but
i'm talking about the
little ones that are at restaurants yeah
why don't you get those where would i
get those
can't you get those you can get those we
have those nobody gets those i have
those
nobody gets those i'll show you them
after the show i have them yeah but
nobody gets them you get a container and
you put it in the refrigerator
that's what you do you but yours is very
big
yeah it's too big it's a cord
don't i know what a quart is but it's
very big for half an hour how is a quart
too big for for a half an hour i'll tell
you why
i i have already thought about this i
love what i've already thought about
something i haven't
been cocked yeah
it looks like regular milk then and i
almost gave it to the baby except that
it says
half and half right on it it does
but when i looked at the whole milk it
was a little bit bigger
and the only thing different about it
was it didn't say half and half it said
whole milk
and you know i have a baby by the way
there was no whole milk in there if
there was
there was two people right two percent
yeah okay and half an hour right two
percent yeah you don't drink coffee and
you grab the half and half
yeah and you poured it into the baby's
bottle
yes i did yeah and then and then you
reacted like i was
putting in ricin you were
you were reacting like i put in a i had
a bottle of rice and i was going to get
you the real reason
i reacted like i did was because you
were using my precious
half of half yeah and i needed it for my
coffee
if it was smaller i would never have
used it it looks too much like the milk
the fact that it says half and half on
it you don't
read the [ __ ] things so closely no
you do
if it's orange you look at it you open
the refrigerator okay
you look at what's there okay and you
take out
what you need cool you don't
just absently take out a carton because
you think it's milk
okay you just don't okay nobody does
that
i think that that's wrong i think what
you're saying is wrong
but i'll i'm gonna let you have that
maybe i'm wrong about that
but you are but okay fine so let's say
i'm wrong
okay we're both saying that you don't
need to keep saying it because we both
said it all right
i'm gonna say it again okay fine but
when you're done saying it i have
something that will add to this whole
[ __ ] thing
okay okay have you ever had grapefruit
juice
yes have you ever i know you're confused
but what i do is i start it a certain
way and then it all comes back
it's like a tarantino movie you don't
know why john travolta gets killed in
the middle and then he's there also
let me explain one thing but i'm not
done but okay i'm not confused
okay i'm i'm traveling with you
okay you've had grapefruit juice yeah
have you ever had pineapple juice
yeah okay now
you keep grapefruit juice in your
in your fridge all the time what's it
look like is it got a little handle it
looks like a
cart you know you got a thing maybe it
looks like that maybe it's a carton
whatever you see it
okay grapefruit yours all the time my
family loves grapefruit juice it doesn't
but in this
hypothetical world my family loves
grapefruit juice we're the grapefruit
juice family okay
we're the family that when you come over
you know you get grapefruit juice
one day you decide to get pineapple
juice
all right it doesn't look that much
different does it
and the only thing different about it is
it says pineapple and not grapefruit
okay i'm pavlov's dog when i'm opening
the fridge
i grab the pineapple juice i drink it
and i drink it and i think what the [ __ ]
pineapple
whose fault is that
whose fault is that is that my fault i
think it's yours
so in essence what you're saying is
whenever you grab a carton
even though you're always there and you
pretty much know what it is
you should read it every time
i'm saying that when you open a
refrigerator yeah
to get something yeah you have to look
before you take it out and use it that's
what i'm saying
it just it i okay all right grapefruit
juice
pineapple juice whatever the [ __ ] and
how do you feel
so and you were upset that i i by
mistake used it because now you didn't
have enough half and half
right i guess that's cool that's fair
not only that you're poisoning your son
no you can feed i looked it up
afterwards it just makes them fatter
okay i'm sorry little kids hey guys
that's it for youtube if you want to
catch the rest of the episode all you
got to do is go to
my patreon which is patreon.comcrystalia
there's the uh the rest of this episode
and
uh the bag backlog of patreon episodes
and all sorts of other stuff so uh go
sign up
[Music]
congratulations
thank you
it's probably annoying with your glasses
is that why you didn't do it
yeah it's just too tight
don't need them